salut j'ai changé et on se retrouve sur
la troisième version donc auspices alors
elle a l'air quand même pas mal plus
glauque je vais pas vous mentir l'air un
peu plus flippante
c'est un peu plus sombre déjà premier
constat si j'étais un homme juste dans
le noir donc lui s'est déjà chaude et là
à côté cholet je suis sûr j'ai développé
une page en plus comme un gosse c'est
des fois je dis qu'il faut c'est pas de
nom sera sûrement d'un lot était quand
même super glue cache pas si l'on fait à
l'image de colo folle histoire dénonce
mais c'était bien gros ici une poche on
était sûr always hunting 2 sur cèze
lines line c'est quoi ces des lignes va
comment ça se passe yako princpaux
guerre on va essayer de ne pas
rencontrer le bad boy bad boy what
you're gonna do what you're gonna do mr
goodfish gbagbo gbagbo il a cassé le mur
nord est avec funcom tender il fait pas
ça non non non non en plus c'est des
feuilles regard des cds ces feuilles
avancée du carrosse
ok gérant dit est capable de casser un
mur pardon excusez moi est ce que je
vois toi couvre tête de [ __ ] faut que je
donne ça salut à toi avec l'ademe le gie
qui se doivent une grosse vague
glycémique bas âge et sans wii jamais
j'appelle ça j'ai encore faim claque
non c'est vrai mais ça faut pas qu'ils
prennent goût je pense à mon attention
il va être là il va être là c'est quoi
ça j'ai cet homme un truc
je peux pas le prendre non ok ap ap ap
hm hockey prend le chou les y'a pas de
soucis je me casse de la vas-y abdou
probasis et tout à toi tu me prends la
dynamique et le tableau même cassé la
vie si tu veux pas casser un mur à vas-y
vas-y vas-y vas-y fais ce que tu veux ça
n'a vraiment là c'est pour toi c'est
pour toi ça tout ça or ici on a une elle
me tue de pâques dans les douches sera
pas une petite feuille une feuille d'un
lac du nom mais là c'est obligé que j'ai
tombé dessus comme blessés voilà c'est
ça que je vous parlais dans notre vidéo
des jeunes truc du genre c'est plutôt
pas mal
j'aime bien les petites bd comme ça par
contre je comprends juste parce qu'il
faut prendre le bon moment
j'ai passé 20 heures je marche il n'y a
rien benfica chaîne ii alors tu fais pas
comme d'habitude tu n'attends pas aux
cons les murs s'il te plaît non mais
c'est pas possible un truc à faire là
non sérieux à part se faire tuer par
semaine de éventuellement il ya autre
chose
là-dessus tient le truc quand tu vas là
dedans c'est que six länder arrive je
suis mort en fait c'est ça qui m'énerve
actuellement je ne sais pas où il est
sûrement peut-être juste l'annoncer
monde peut-être là non c'est bon ben
voilà non mais que dois-je faire des tas
je fais le tour de l'hospice 40 fois
faut que je récupère des trucs on va
cliquer partout
des fois ça marche va cliquer sur send
heures peut-être que je vais le ramasser
cette année de plus en cabine jardin ce
jeu confort aulas y a un truc là c'est
parce länder non c'est un bug s'appelle
jules courjal attardé on peut pas sortir
toi un truc c'est pas possible ah mais
c'est pas possible il ya forcément un
truc en dehors du slender évidemment bon
je n'y crois pas
il m'a de bronze tulipes hi he was
pierre un instant dur par contre les 16
länder je suis mort voilà je suis mort
je suis obligée d'aller vers lui et
votre âme tu veux pas tu as battu et
c'est bon j'étais tendu
c'est très tendu je comprends toujours
pas où sont les pages mais à part ça
tout va bien non mais c'est pas possible
les gens ya quelque chose là où sont les
deux pages il ya un truc lâche pas là un
patrick a fait je vais arthur d armand
il me fait flipper le cloud coton tige
ya forcément quelque chose à faire à
on page 16 mai 4 sur 16 [ __ ] c'est à
dire le mur cassé j'avais pas vu tien au
une autre page aubin série de deux
poches pourtant il y avait tout à
l'heure je suis passé là je me souviens
y avait pas la page
au sam bird tellement avatar est
tellement un bâtard à bientôt une
prochaine vidéo
[Musique]